fue un día histórico para el Manchester
City por primera vez se coronó en la
Champions imponiéndose como mejor club
de Europa para la inmensa alegría de sus
fans
una de las mejores noches de mi vida
vieron a todo el mundo adentro Fue
increíble
el club inglés luchó durante casi 70
minutos contra el Inter de Milán hasta
el gol del español Rodrigo
es todo por lo que he estado luchando
durante muchos años ya sabes es
increíble hemos sido capaces de
conseguirlo con el city es la primera
vez en la historia del club Así que
siempre estaremos asociados al club por
eso es realmente especial
en Italia los fans que esperaban ver su
Club llevarse su cuarto título de
Champions quedaron muy decepcionados
ha sido un buen partido lo Hemos jugado
en igualdad de condiciones teníamos la
esperanza de poder hacerlo era esperado
que perdiéramos Pero igualmente tenía
Esperanza esperaba tener una gran noche
e irme de fiesta no fue así pero no
importa Hemos llegado hasta aquí lo
volveremos a intentar el año que viene
probaremos el próximo año esta temporada
ha sido particularmente buena para el
Manchester City que logró un triplete
ganando también la Premier League y la f
cap la primera vez para un club inglés
desde 1999 cuando lo logró el Manchester
uni